good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about the definition of
success over to you Tony Hsieh awake
misread school BB go the ultimate
definition of success is you could lose
everything that you have and truly be
okay with you your happiness isn't based
on external factors could you lose
everything and be happy I think that
would actually be a fun challenge I love
modeling success that's why I made this
channel and I love hearing how different
successful people break down what
success means to them because I think we
can learn a lot from it I love Tony's
definition because it's it's different
it's not what you would expect most
people to think of when they think of
what is success for me success is all
about happiness I want to be happy
that's my end goal and I'm happiest when
I am doing the work that I love doing
when I'm doing it with the people who I
want to do it with that's my definition
of success and my question the day for
you today is what's your definition of
success leave it in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events peso expresso give
me go